When it comes to anxiety disorders, there is no 'one type'. Each form of anxiety has its own set of symptoms and treatments
It is important to remember that, while some symptoms will overlap. No two anxiety disorders are alike
This list aims to bring attention to the five major anxiety disorders, and what they mean for the sufferers
We at psych2go hope to bring awareness to the growing number of anxiety sufferers and their needs
So, without further ado, here's five anxiety disorders as well as their symptoms and treatments
Number one: obsessive compulsive disorder or OCD
Obsessive compulsive disorder technically has two components: the obsessions and the compulsions
Obsessions can encompass anything from a severe fear of germs to the placement of things around the home and many things in between
The compulsions are what the sufferer does to rid themselves of those obsessive thoughts
Someone who has obsessions about germs may ritually wash their hands or carry hand sanitizer everywhere they go
Someone who has obsessive thoughts about the placement of objects might arrange and rearrange their belongings until they feel just right
These obsessions and compulsions can become very intruisive and disrupted to the sufferers daily life
As far as treatments for OCD go, there are a couple:
There are selective serotonin reuptake inhibitors such as fluoxetine sertraline
These medications are meant to help alleviate the symptoms for the sufferer so that they are at a manageable and less destructive level
The other widely used treatment is psychotherapy
With this, you might run into cognitive behavioral therapy that will be used to help the sufferer essentially reprogram their response to obsessions and compulsions
For the most part, medications and therapies are used in tandem to get the best results
Number two: generalized anxiety disorder
Generalized anxiety disorder or GED is a bit unlike the other anxiety disorders on this list
Those who suffer from GED aren't always able to give a reason for their symptoms
In fact, one of the symptoms is a general feel of restlessness or an ease
They may also experience worry as one of the symptoms
Everyone worries from time to time, but GED causes the sufferer to eternalize those worries and take them to an entirely new level
They may think of them in an obsessive manner which will cause a downward spiral of other symptoms such as a disturbance in sleep patterns
The treatments available for GED are similar to those of OCD
Medications and therapy. Though in this case the medications may be benzodiazepines and antidepressants rather than the run-of-the-mill SSRIs
Cognitive behavioral therapy is used with GED as well as relaxation techniques and mindfulness
Number three: social anxiety disorder
Those with social anxiety disorder experienced panic attacks related to social situations
This can manifest in a fear of public speaking or stage fright, and can be so severe that they avoid going into public altogether
Social anxiety can also have symptoms of severe self-consciousness and a general fear of being around others
Someone with social anxiety might find it hard to speak when other people are present even if they aren't addressing the crowd as a whole
Social anxiety is mainly treated with SSRIs and therapy
As we stated before, just because a treatment option looks similar from one anxiety to another it isn't going to be the same
Each sufferer presents their own needs that must be taken into account. Each therapy isn't going to work the same for each individual
Personalization of treatment is key in these situations
Number four: panic disorder
Unlike the other anxiety disorders on this list, panic disorder rests solely on panic attacks
With many other anxiety disorders, panic attacks are just another symptom when it comes to panic disorder those attacks are the symptom
Panic disorder is characterized by recurrent panic attacks
The sufferer may experience heart palpitations, erasing pulse an intense fear and the feeling that they are hopelessly out of control
There isn't a rhyme or reason to many of these attacks, so the sufferer is essentially lying in wait for the next one to come
Panic disorder can be treated in many ways
The medications used are some that we've heard of such as benzodiazepines and SSRIs
We are also introduced to serotonin norepinephrine reuptake inhibitors or SNRIs and beta blockers
These medications, as with OCD, are often used in conjunction with therapy to help maximize the usefulness of each
Number 5: post-traumatic stress disorder
Post-traumatic stress disorder or PTSD can be diagnosed in anyone
For the most part you have probably heard it, when someone speaks about veterans or police officers
While those careers have a higher rate of PTSD, it is in fact true that anyone can be diagnosed with it
PTSD is the result of a very traumatic event or series of events
This leaves the sufferer with flashbacks and night terrors where they feel as if they are right back in the event again
The sufferer may also suffer from panic attacks as well as phobias associated with people places or even sounds
Medications such as fluoxetine venlafaxine may be used in the treatment of PTSD
Therapies such as prolonged exposure, cognitive processing therapy, and brief eclectic psychotherapy may be utilized as well
Again, this is a situation where the use of medications and therapy together can help give a better outcome than just one alone
It is important to note that those with PTSD can lash out in certain situations
But there is no need to be afraid of the sufferers
There is nothing inherently dangerous about them
In fact those with mental illness are exponentially more likely to be the victims of violent crimes than they are to be the perpetrator
This is not a complete list of the different anxiety disorders out there by any means, nor is it completely comprehensive in each description
There are many kinds of anxiety, these just happen to be the most talked about and diagnosed at this particular moment
Regardless of which anxiety disorder the diagnosis is for, it is important to remember that the sufferer is in need of help and acceptance
You don't have to understand anxiety to be able to offer an ear to talk to, or some words to keep them grounded in the moment
Remind the sufferer that they are alright, that what they are feeling are just symptoms of their anxiety and that it will pass if given the time
Aside from that, just make sure that they know you are there with them and wait it out
Do you suffer from one or more of the disorders listed?
Share your story in the comments below
On a different note, psych2go is now selling t-shirts. Links will be in the description below.
As always, don't forget to subscribe and thanks for watching